all right we're now live for session 10
of understanding anger 2.0 so this is a
class that I've been doing off and on I
intended for it to be monthly but didn't
always get to it every single month uh
talk about the structure of the class in
a bit um it came out of a face tof face
class that I was teaching at Marquette
University for undergraduates having to
do with anger a semester long class but
also out of an earlier set of uh
in-person
presentations that I did back in
2015 it would be at the Kingston public
library and invited monthly lecture
Series where we looked at literature and
philosophy and religious texts dealing
with with the emotion of anger and
people were you know interested in that
and said why don't you restart it so
that's what this is this may go on for
quite a long time because there's a lot
of texts thinkers movements approaches
that have to do with anger that I think
could be quite interesting for us as
people who are going to study the
phenomenon and who have to deal with
with anger so today we're going to be
starting uh a new chapter let's say
we've looked at quite a bit of ancient
Greek literature some epic some other
poetry like hessed um some some Greek
tragedies as well we're gonna back to
that sort of stuff again we've also
spent two sessions each on Plato and
Aristotle to early important
philosophical theorist so now we're
going to be looking at another
philosophical school that was very
important in ancient times and has had
some attraction for people in uh the
Renaissance early modern times all the
way down to the present and that is the
epicurian School founded by
epicurus and it's uh quite different
than Plato and Aristotle in a number of
important respects that we'll we'll talk
about in just a bit so I'm envisioning
spending two sessions on the
epicurian this one we're going to be
focused mostly on what we've got from
epicurus himself and then from this uh
Latin poet who was an
epicurian uh lucretius who wrote a
philosophical poem which is kind of a
digest of epicurian teachings and
arguments called on the uh nature of
things there is a really important
epicurian thinker who I'm going to put
off most of the discussion till the next
time that we look at the epicurian down
the line and that's a guy called Phil o
damus and we're not doing him next time
in part because I'm actually hoping that
we we get our hands on some additional
sources so um there you know why why
that well we should explain it you may
have seen the news recently uh articles
that have been in all sorts of source is
about them managing to use AI to
decipher some of the Scrolls that were
found in the library of
herculanum so that appears to have been
uh a largely epicurian library and that
is where we get a lot of philus who we
know existed from from other authors who
talk about him that's where we've gotten
his recently acquired texts um he has a
work called on anger which we'll look at
in in a later session but unfortunately
it's kind of fragmentary because when
they were able to get the text open they
they messed it up a good bit um he's
also got some other works that are kind
of relevant like on Frank speech uh
which is Perry
pares um we're gonna put off talking
about him till till a later session I
think because we've got enough to talk
about with
epicurus and other people's takes on him
and lucretius so the epicureans are
going to be um providing us with a
Viewpoint that's alternative to the ones
that we've seen so far in two really
important ways and one way has to do
with um we could call it cosmology and
theology the epicurian do believe that
there are gods and you can talk
meaningfully about them but the god
don't feel anger so what does that mean
for us human beings you don't need to
spend your life what you have of it
worried about a bad afterlife or that
the gods are going to be angry with you
for whatever reason and do bad things to
you right that is not something that
needs to be on your radar and as a
matter of fact for the epicurian it's
not just um that it's it's something you
don't need to think about if you are
thinking about it you are going to screw
up your life and you're doing bad things
not just to yourself but to other people
by passing on these mistaken ideas so
that's that's where uh you could say
that that uh epicurus and Lucius are
going to differ from the poets that we
we've seen so far like Homer and hiad
and the Greek tragedians
achelis um uh Ides who has Athena being
being mad at at people or no Sophocles
sorry and then Ides where Meda is is you
know sort of very angry there isn't that
much of divine anger in that H
particular thing although it's invoked
on her now epicurus is also differing
from Plato and Aristotle in a massively
important way he is what we call a
hedonist so whereas Aristotle and Plato
didn't say that pleasure a bad
thing leads us astray and there are
better things greater Goods than
pleasure for the epicurian human
happiness consists in a life that has as
much pleasure and as little pain as
possible and Pleasure and Pain are the
things that we're supposed to be using
Consulting thinking about in order to uh
govern our lives in order to be in touch
with things and wisd wisdom practical
wisdom Prudence foron Asis consists in
understanding these these sorts of
matters now we're not going to have as
systematic a perspective on anger as we
had with Aristotle with the epicurian
and we will have later with the stoics
who we're going to look at in a few
months but we do have some discussions
about anger and this is part of a larger
systematic philosophical perspective
much of which unfortunately is is lost
so here's what we're going to do in
today's session um I'm going to talk
about the sources that we actually have
because this presents a certain kind of
problem we're going to do a little
history lesson about how this school
became important we'll talk about the
broader teachings that the epicurian
have like their key ideas and practices
and doctrines then we'll zoom in on
epicurus epicurus's and and epicurian
teachings about anger and then we'll see
what lucretius adds to the picture and
we'll we'll take pauses for Q&A and
comments and discussion at various
points and you can leave whatever you
want in the chat you know if I'm uh uh
in the middle of explaining something I
may not respond to it immediately but
you you know it's it's there I see it so
we can uh certainly grapple with any of
these sorts of things it is not an a ma
where you just ask questions about
anything whatsoever this is about anger
and epicurian philosophy but you can ask
anything that you like that's that's
connected to that so let's talk about
sources right what do we actually have
epicurus according to ancient sources
was one of the most prolific authors in
all of
antiquity unfortunately what we have of
him is actually just a tiny tiny little
selection even one% of what he wrote so
what we do have is something that's
called the principal doctrines or
sometimes an older text you'll see it
called The Sovereign maxims that's uh 40
odd short passages drawn from his work
sort of like epictetus's and cidian
right it's like a little tiny handbook
we have a similar thing in the Vatican
sayings which are 81 short passages
which were discovered in a 14th century
manuscript in the Vatican library and
there's some uh overlap between the two
of those there's some passages that are
the same so we've got two doxography
right two presentations of epicurus's
idea have three letters um two of which
are about natural philosophy there's
there's technically four letters but one
of them is only like two lines so we
don't worry about that the letter to uh
man mosus is the one that's about ethics
and so that's the one that's more
relevant to us and then we have you know
a bunch of fragments here and there in
other texts by other authors who I'll
talk about in just a bit usually hostile
to
epicureanism and then we have a will he
actually left a uh last will and
testament behind about how his resources
ought to be shared how his school ought
to be continued um doesn't turn out
anything to with anger particularly but
it's interesting that he had a will now
um lost
texts we might actually find these uh
there's prospects that perhaps these
herculanum Scrolls might have some of
these lost texts that we uh simply
haven't had access to for you know two
Millennia so he wrote a 37 book that's
37 Scrolls book on nature and and
perhaps that contains some discussions
of the human emotions and how they work
so you know that would be great he's
also he had a book on love which might
have something to do with anger on
choice and avoidance which is about you
know practical reasoning and
prioritization uh a book on life
probably has some references to anger un
just dealing um you know actually on
just Behavior right Behavior which
probably has some stuff about anger but
we don't know because we don't have the
text and then finally he wrote a book on
the emotions also called against
timates that would definitely have a
discussion of anger and perhaps that's
some of the stuff that we see being
referred to by other authors who
probably had access to those documents
but we don't have them so we only have
book titles which are nice and promising
uh we do have laucius as I mentioned
this great uh poem The the nature of
things and he provides us with many of
epicurus's teachings
reinterpreted in his own time and for
all we know he may be drawing on
epicurus's book on on nature then we
have of course philus of GAD who we're
going to talk about more in a subsequent
session um you know the the library at
herculanum where all of these Scrolls
were were burned but have been you know
safely recovered and are now being
scanned um that's you know promising
maybe we'll get a lot more of his stuff
there's also this very interesting
inscription of epicurian texts on a wall
uh dating back to the first century ad
that was commissioned by diogenes of
oand and I'll mention a passage from
that a little bit later on but it's
interesting when we want to read Plato
we read Plato right when we want to read
Aristotle we read Aristotle if we want
to know about the epicurian and what
epicurus himself taught sometimes
sometimes we have to go to the critics
of the epicurian and basically everybody
in ancient times who wasn't an epicyon
was a Critic of the epicurian they
didn't have any fellow tra
or Allies or anything like that so who
would we go to so for epicurian
teachings more broadly we have Cicero
who has a book called on the ends book
one is an epicurian torquatus presenting
the epicurian doctrine and uh we'll talk
about a little bit of that um Cicero is
is having him sort of setting him up to
knock him down afterwards uh book one of
on the nature of the Gods you have
another epican present the epican
position on the gods and then there's a
book called The academics where Cicero
is is epican thought in terms of
epistemology or the theory of knowledge
and why they're why they're wrong about
stuff um there's also a guy who's not a
philosopher so much aanus who wrote a
book called the um it's often called the
sopus at dinner the philosophers at
dinner the dpos sophista the wise people
at at dinner and he portrays the
epicurian as being harsh or you know
very Frank in conveying truth and it
doesn't say much more about that um we
do get Plutarch who talks a good bit
about the epicurian also not a fan of
them and the main work we'd want to look
at with that is that it's not possible
to live pleas pleasurably according to
the doctrine of epicurus where he's
explicitly criticizing them why would we
want to look at that because he'll say
here's what the epicurian think here's
why they're wrong right so that can be
quite quite helpful and then we actually
have a very early Christian Author L
tonus who writes a book called The Anger
of God and he tells us about what the
epicureans thought again in order to say
how they've gotten things
wrong so those are the sources that
we're going to be relying upon let's
talk a little bit about their history
and then maybe we'll stop for a little
Q&A and then jump into epicurian
doctrines so epicurus is one of the few
philosophers of his time who is outside
of the you could say the the influence
or lineage of
Socrates um he is coming from the
outside arrives at Athens after having
taught in mellene and then lakus um
where he's actually he's leaving because
he's being uh he and his friends are
being um kind of you know
persecuted and he founds a a place
called The Garden and that's what the
epicurian um school is actually often
called the the garden uh between the
stoa where the stoics are stoa poil and
the
academy um the stoa later on and he he
creates a kind of Society of Friends In
the Garden you know sort of a well you
could call it a commune if you want
right he's got enough money they they
can eat they can drink they hang out to
together he teaches writes has uh
friendly relations with people not
interested in sex not super interested
in Gourmet dining or anything like that
very interested in natural phenomena and
talking with with people and um you know
he's going to live there for quite a
while he's got a a good friend uh
metrodorus who's an early popularizer of
epicurian philosophy and he would have
been the natural successor to epicurus
but unfortunately he dies about seven
years before epicurus leaving a son
named epicurus and a daughter in the
garden and epicurus provides for them in
his
will after that we get as we usually do
with ancient philosophy what are called
skolars you know leaders of the school
in the Athenian garden and the
epicureans spread out through through um
the you could say the the macedonians uh
um successor States and into the Roman
Empire as well so you can find him all
over the place you can find him any any
place that philosophy is Big you can
after a while find epicurian becomes
quite influential in Roman circles so
we've got this guy torquatus as a prime
representative some people wanted to say
that that Julius Caesar was in fact an
epicurian probably doubtful he doesn't
appear to have been super super
interested in
philosophy um but you know the the idea
like being a pleasure Seeker that for a
lot of people was um viewed as being
epicurian and he influences certain
poets for example
Horus and as I mentioned there's a lot
of people who are critical of the Epic
carens um and so you know they've got uh
quite a few other schools all of whom
agree that epicurian are they're not as
bad as the other hedonists but they're
not good because they make pleasure the
measure of what is good so the stoics
the aristotelians the platonists the
cynics the Skeptics they all have beefs
with the epicurian and we'll actually
see that um you know there's there's
also medical people who are interested
in epicureanism because they have a
physical uh account again if we had
epicurus's book on nature we'd know more
about that but we don't and epicureanism
kind of takes a nose dive in late and
but we see revivals of it in the
Renaissance and in the early modern
period so just to give you a few
examples you may have heard of Pierre
gassendi uh and you think about him in
terms of like gases and physical things
like that he was actually a Catholic
priest and a philosopher and a
correspondent of Renee deheart and he
was an
epicurian um nonon de Leno who is a
little bit later is a French woman who
writes a very interesting book about
love and it's from an epican perspective
um there's many others as well there's
people who are influenced by the
epicurian to some degree and um you know
very often this was tied with a very
worldly way of looking at things a
hedonistic way of looking at things and
you can can say that epicureanism feeds
into what we think of as the
Enlightenment and there are epicurian
around today it is probably I would say
the second largest group of people
interested in classical philosophy and
applying it as a way of life in the
present um including somebody who's not
far from where I currently am in
Milwaukee uh here in creso down in
Chicago right so it's it's it's a
philosophy with some legs you could say
so i' I've already thrown a lot of stuff
at you any any
questions uh comments clarifications
needed at this point um we'll uh jump
shortly into talking about the doctrines
of the epicurian in general and then
we'll talk about have to say about Ang
but maybe there's a few things people
want to bring
up
it doesn't look like there's any so
maybe we'll we'll put that off until a
little bit later so what do the
epicurian believe um they're
materialists meaning that they think
that everything is matter and they're
also atomists they think that everything
is little bits of matter that you can't
divide any further um they've got this
idea that they're taking from
democratus um about Adams falling in the
void but then uh epicurus also
introduces this idea of like Randomness
or they call it the swerve every once in
a while one of these things zigs instead
of zags and that's where we get freedom
from they also as I mentioned earlier
they believe that there are Gods but
they're a very different kind of God
than what you find in mythology these
are Gods who are supremely happy and you
know in a certain sense provide us with
a great example because they don't care
about anything that happens in the world
as a matter of fact they're not even in
the world they're in you know they talk
about the interes these these places
between different worlds the epicurian
by the way believed in a universe with
many many worlds and these these gods
they don't get themselves mixed up with
the Affairs of us messy stupid human
beings that's why they're happy because
they stay out of things that would
aggravate
them um epicurus and and his followers
devoted a lot of attention to Natural
philosophy or physics and the reasons
that they did this were really twofold
one was they thought that that was
enjoyable you know if you're a person
who likes learning makes sense right
they also thought it's really important
to understand the way the universe works
so you don't believe all this silly
stuff that other people are telling you
about the gods if you don't think the
gods are going to get angry at you you
don't have to fear the gods right um so
that's that's an important part they
also another thing that they thought was
a um a sort of baseless or groundless or
empty we say fear was the fear of death
and the epicurian have a lot of
interesting discussions about why we
don't have to worry about being dead
probably the easiest one is the one that
epicus s says namely that um you know
when you're dead there's no you to be
worried about anything um once you're
once you're uh Gone there's no you
there's it's it's not even a question so
until you're actually dead you don't
really need to worry about dying and you
said Well why'd you write a will then
well obviously epicurus knows that other
people are going to be around
afterwards um now kids Study Hour says
they don't consider the M themselves
like everyone else I'm not sure what
that means so you're probably going to
have to explain that like everybody else
in in what way um they also think that
because they're materialists that
sensation is a reliable guide to truth
um along with what they call
preconceptions which are sort of General
Notions that we have that we apply to
things this is also something that the
stoics will will talk about and then we
get to Hedonism so we that's their
physical Stu
ethically they think that pleasure is
the fundamental good pain or trouble is
the fundamental bad so you want to set
your life up and make your decisions and
establish your priorities in such a way
as to give yourself the most Pleasant
life possible now does that mean you
should party all the time and you know
get drunk and try to have as much sex as
possible no it's not that kind of
Hedonism U it's not sex drugs and rock
and roll constantly and it's kind of
interesting if you look at old rock and
rollers they can't quite keep that up
all the time can they um and so what is
the ultimate goal being untroubled
ataraxia not being uh Disturbed or
shaken by things a pleasant life that is
free of of pain as much as possible and
so they're going to make a couple
important distinctions you know if you
want to understand Pleasures you have to
study if you want to understand pains
you have to study them as well so one of
the biggest things that is often
difficult for people to wrap their head
around the greatest Pleasures according
to the epicurian are not what they call
moving or kinetic Pleasures so I think
about when you actually eat something
right you uh enjoy what you're eating
and you're you're you know taking some
pleasure in it um or you know having sex
or things like that they involve some
sort of action or or change they are
positive in a sense then they have what
are called Static or kemic pleasures and
these arise when pain or trouble is
removed so you know you can enjoy taking
a
drink because you're thirsty and now the
pain of thirst is removed and that sort
of
evenness um that is a greater pleasure
than the initial taste that you're
giving with the thing so the rest the
relaxation that comes with things is a
positive state for them and so this is
quite important if you're going to
govern your life right they also talk
about the difference between pleasures
of the just the body itself and
pleasures of the mind and bodily
Pleasures are you feel them while you
have them same with bodily pains right
but we're we're creatures that have
memory and can anticipate things coming
ahead and we can appreciate aspects of
things that are not just at the level of
you know animal bodies we have we have
Minds right now the minds are material
so that's that's important um and so you
know mental pleasures and mental pains
can be much more intense lasting than
just physical pleasures and this is
where the epicureans differed from many
of the other hedonists uh for example
the serc school of aristippus who said
physical pleasure that's where it is man
don't worry about the mental stuff just
concentrate on on the fun stuff in which
case you got to keep yourself being
stimulated all the time right um the
other thing that they're going to talk
about which is really
important is a distinction between not
just Pleasures but desires what is it
that we want so we want things that we
feel are going to give us pleasure that
are are going to provide us with good
feelings right and epicurus will say you
got three basic kinds and you could
think of it as a square that where one
part of it is is missing so you've got
what's natural and what's unnatural or
not natural and then you've got what's
necessary and what's not
necessary so you've got um oh it's good
to see heram crespos here this is quite
amazing so happy to see him here and
answering questions just mentioned him
earlier in the conversation uh we've
never actually met up although you know
that's more an issue for for me since
we're so close by but in any case so let
me go on so we got three three sort of
categories right we got the natural and
necessary and opposed to that would be
the UN the not natural not necessary and
then we've got things that are natural
but they're not necessary so you know we
could think about
um sexuality as falling into the the
natural but not necessary I mean there's
some people who are like oh if I don't
have sex I'm going to die no you're not
uh epicurus actually you know thought it
was just fine to not get it on with
anybody and there's all sorts of
possibilities of of having you know sex
in ways or pursuing sex in ways that are
you know kind not not really natural
from the the ancient point of view uh
you could think of all the fetishes that
people have out there that are readily
available for you know perusal on the
internet but another great example is
food right you you you will die if you
don't eat right so you know what you
need to eat is in order to stay alive is
not a huge wide range of things and you
know the natural and necessary that can
be supplied very easily and then we can
have things that are natural but they're
not necessary and then we can have all
sorts of crazy ideas and this is where
like restaurants come in right um I need
to have tacos and they better be made
with this kind of ingredient and they
must be served to me on silver plates or
Golden Plates or pick whatever else you
want or the decor of the restaurant must
be that's that's neither natural nor
necessary and our ideas about what you
know our the things that promote our
desires for those sorts of things are
going to be um what what uh the
epicurian call empty opinion or vain
opinion kenoia right um wrongheaded
ideas you could say unfounded is another
translation of this so um that's
something really Central there's there's
two other little bits and pieces that I
want to bring up um so there's this
wonderful little saying that you see
repeated at a number of points from
epicurus and in the literature you can't
live pleasantly so you can't can't
actually live a the life that you want
without living
prudently justly and it could be
translated as well or as beautifully um
Kos in in Greek and Prudence is needed
practical wisdom because you got to
figure out what you should say yes to
and what you should say no to right
that's very important how do you
prioritize how do you choose between the
pleasures that are calling out to
you and then Justice turns out to be
really important for the epicurian as
well and now they don't think that
there's any sort of absolute Justice
that holds every single place it's based
on a sort of usefulness and uh but it is
based on natural Norms that are going to
be pretty constant across societies
people don't want to be harmed right so
there's a kind of social agreement
there's Mutual advantage or usefulness
and why is this important you don't want
to to have a unpleasant life with other
people doing things to you and if you do
the wrong thing you might get punished
you might have a guilty conscience you
know so those are important and then the
last thing that I'll say about epicurian
Doctrine and we'll jump into the
conversation before we get to the anger
part friendship is also centrally
important for epicurus by the way in our
uh online um uh ancient philosophers on
friendship next week is devoted to the
epicurian on friendship uh for my
students who are enrolled in that class
and uh the epicurian uh took a lot of
heat from other ancient philosophers who
like well you heeden this you can't
really believe in Friendship you're just
you're friends with people just for what
you can get from them you're not really
friends and the epicurian produce some
you know arguments to say no no
friendship you could start it out
because it's you know you're getting
pleasure from somebody or some sort of
usefulness but eventually you know as as
the the song goes I've become accustomed
to your face right you get used to
people and you value them for your for
their own sake and it also does provide
with security and enjoyment and this is
a great place to go to the uh question
from virtual NATA can pleasure also
arise from witnessing the pleasure of
another being yeah um you can you can
this is what happens in friendship right
you want your friend to actually enjoy
themselves it would be weird if you were
like o I don't care about my friend
pleasure is the good I don't care about
my friend having a good time right or
even just random strangers um seeing
them being made Happy in certain ways
probably good and conversely you could
be pained at seeing the undeserved pain
or the pain that's caused by imprudence
of other people and by the way so this
is a bit of a a jump if we move forward
into the 18th century and onward where
utilitarianism is a hedonistic Doctrine
this is exactly what benthem calls
benevolence where you feel pleasure at
seeing the pleasure of another person or
even thinking about the pleasure of
another person likewise pain after
pain um
all right I'm gonna I'm going to skip
over the the discussions about um
Francis Wright um but I'll just say
there's there's lots of of epicurian and
people influenced by epicurian ISM out
there in the the Modern Age um any other
questions about like General doctrines
for the um for the epicurian I almost
said utilitarians I will also say with
English gal we're not discussing spok
this is about Epic carians this is about
the emotion of anger and stuff like that
so it's not a general AMA but any other
questions about
epicurian
Doctrine before I move on to talking
about
anger while I'm while we're teeing those
up I'll say there's really two main
things two main domains that we can talk
about when it comes to anger there's
questions about the anger of the Gods
and remember the epicurian the gods
don't get angry and then there is us
poor mortal saps down here and how anger
works for us and we know that we get
angry right so all right so um kids
study now kindness friendship and living
civil with each other is some of the
characteristics of epicurian I gather
based on your explanation yeah you know
the the epicurian in ancient times would
organize these little
communities and um you know it's not
that they wouldn't be nice to other
people but it was felt like you know the
garden is kind of a model and there are
uh epicurian groups all the way down to
the present um you know there's an
online sort of worldwide epicurian
community that that Iram is a a
significant part of and leader within I
should recommend too and I don't know
ham do you want to put a link to your
book tending the epicurian garden into
the chat uh because I I recommend that
to to people as a good source for
contemporary epicurian ISM and there's a
discussion of of precisely what kids
study now is is talking about in there
all right well let's let's talk about
anger so the gods right Maxim one says
the gods are Fe free from feeling anger
Ur or what we could call favoritism it's
translated in different ways
gratitude is the the Greek and why
because these movements imply a certain
kind of weakness a
dependency so if you're an epicurian you
think that the gods are independent of
all of that sort of stuff um in the the
wall incription we have this this cool
fragment uh that says let us contradict
Homer who talks all sorts of nonsense
about them representing them etc etc etc
um you with with the wrong sorts of of
ways some statue of God shoot arrows and
are produced holding a bow represented
like Hercules and Homer others are
attended by a bodyguard of wild beasts
other are angry with the prosperous
oftentimes the Greek gods were portrayed
as being angry and there's lots of words
for that in Homer and hassad or is being
envious thonos um is is a bad state of
emotion
and then they you know they do bad
things and so it it concludes so we can
smile back at them rather than be afraid
of them right worrying about the gods
being angry with you is a mistaken or
empty opinion that's just been
circulated around throughout Society
according to the
epicurian um so in Plutarch in his it's
not possible to live pleasurably
according to the doctrine of epic
cus and lonus are both saying some
interesting things he says God is good
and that he is and he that is good can
on no account fall into now notice the
different emotions Envy fear anger or
hatred for it's not proper to a hot
thing to cool but to heat nor to a good
thing to do harm now anger is by nature
at the farthest distance imaginable from
as this is the translation complacency
or haris
right or is distance from haris spenish
from placidness so spenish is holos um
another word for anger that we've
encountered in in many of the Greek
writings from uh UMAS a peaceful mind
and uh animosity and turbulence from
humanity and kindness Phil anthrop okay
philanth uh
philoponus to do Menace de menace menace
is wrath right and so de Menace is like
wrath that's even worse now this is
plutar setting out at this point a
position that's compatible with the
Epicurean position and then he'll say
for the latter of these proceed from
generosity and fortitude the former from
impotency and baseness so the the God is
Not constrained by either anger or
kindness now here's where he's going to
differ from the epicurian so the
epicurian gods they don't get angry they
also don't exhibit gratitude kindness
favoritism Plutarch says Ah they're
right about one wrong about the other um
it's natural to God to be kind and
aiding unnatural to be angry and and
hurtful um a little bit later on in in
time lonus and on the anger of God which
is a very important document for
gleaning some some ideas about the
epicurian
he says that the epicurian say that as
there is no anger in God there is no
kindness when epicurus thought it was
inconsistent with God to injure and
inflict harm which for the most part
arises from the affectation of anger he
took from him beneficence also since
it's he he thought that it followed if
God is anger he must also have kindness
so he deprives God of all emotions or
the gods of all emotions and that's
where lanus thinks um like plutar the
epicureans have gone wrong so what can
we take from this um epicurus they they
agree with him in saying that God isn't
going to get angry with lonus God does
get angry but not the way human beings
do you know it's not an
anthropomorphized anger uh with Plutarch
he's saying yeah the epicurian are right
God doesn't get angry um they just think
that the epicurian are wrong and that
God doesn't have positive emotions
towards human beings so you know that's
an interesting negative teaching what
about us us poor slobs down here in this
world so there's a great uh Vatican
saying from that that set of uh do
doctrines if parents have caused to be
angry with their children of course it
is foolish to resist and thus not try to
beg for
forgiveness but if they do not have
cause and are angry without reason it is
ridiculous to make an appeal to one who
is irrationally opposed to hearing such
an appeal and thus not try to convince
him by other means in a spirit of Good
Will so you could apply this to not just
parents and children but anybody where
there's a power relationship or perhaps
even equals it could be spouses you know
romantic Partners if they're if they're
angry with us for good cause and notice
for epicurian it is possible to be angry
with good cause right they're not saying
anger is always bad the way the stoics
will or the way that some Christian
authors will um they they're not saying
that most of our anger is good most of
our anger actually is off base um you
know angry without good reason people
have their reasons but they're not
usually good reasons and so you know
we're getting a really important
distinction here
if we think about wanting to live well
pleasantly free of pains and fears um we
can now bring these epicurian doctrines
in and think about implications so if
we're going to live prudently well and
justly how compatible is this with
feeling anger acting on anger having an
angry disposition being somebody who's
you know ready to to blow up at other
people or making others angry an
epicurian now epicurus doesn't say this
in the text that we have but we don't
have that much right would be saying you
know think about whether it's actually
prudent whether
it's it's beautiful or fine to let
yourself get all angry about trivial
things that don't matter so much or
whether it's just um in terms of Living
Well Kos which could be honorably or
beautifully you know anger very often
doesn't appear all that attractive and I
would guess that the ancient epicurian
thought that you probably want to try to
avoid this anger also can get in the way
of prudence it has a tendency that we
saw with Aristotle and Plato to lead our
practical reasoning astray um it also
involves pain in feeling anger and it
leads us to things that we think are
going to be pleasant like Achilles said
anger pleasant as honey dripping from
the comb but when you see what your
anger has done we can see that same
Achilles looking around and being likeoh
man this isn't good you know think about
the arguments that we have with people
think about the um think about all of
the uh mean things that we say or
decisions that we make those might not
be that prudent and you know in terms of
Justice the point of justice is that we
neither harm nor be harmed that we
follow laws and agreements ments does
anger serve this social purpose
sometimes epicurian think it does so if
you're actually being harmed then it
makes sense to um to retaliate in Anger
to you know maybe push people away or
criticize and to be angry that's what
they later on Phil aamus will call
Natural anger and even the the wise
person feels that but it's because
you're actually being hared a lot of
people think they're being harmed when
they're not being harmed and then they
do things and an epicurian could say
well that's that's unjust right um the
distinction between different kinds of
desires some states of anger uh would
seem to involve neither natural nor
necessary desires and arise from empty
opinion so examples of this Revenge
fantasies when you're thinking in your
head oh I'm gonna get that son of a
[__] who crossed me right you know and
it could be trivial sort of things those
are probably going going to be empty or
vain opinions that you've got rattling
around in your head where did you get
them from maybe your parents your
environment the media but the point
isn't where you got them from the point
is that they're actually wrong and
getting you in trouble um demanding that
other people agree with your perspective
which is also very common when you're
angry you know you're expecting them to
buy into as we say that we're expecting
them to cosign our nonsense again from
an epicurian point of view probably a
bad idea if you've got a whole bunch of
wrongheaded empty vain opinions and
you've got desires for things that are
neither natural nor
necessary you're probably GNA get angry
a lot of the time because life is going
to interfere with that other people are
going to interfere with that right if
you need everything to be just so you're
kind of setting yourself up for a life
of aggra
ation and um you know there's a great
observation in in the Vatican sayings
poverty is great wealth if measured by
the goals of Nature and wealth is abject
poverty if not limited by the the goals
of nature so you know if social status
or wealth or fame or stuff like that is
what you're really aiming at you're
you're not going to be able to satisfy
yourself and you're going to get angry
with other people or you're going to get
angry with Facebook or YouTube or
whatever right uh he's a couple other
examples like this in the Vatican saying
the stomach is not insatiable as most
people say what's uh in what's false is
the opinion that the stomach needs
unlimited filling right or the esteem of
others is outside our control we must
instead attend to Healing ourselves or
the ingratitude of the Soul makes an
animal greedy for Endless variation on
its way of life these are all ways of
talking about having wrongheaded
ideas and um getting ourselves all mixed
up about this so I'm I'm actually G to
pause for a second and take some of
these uhh questions from virtual nura
many people throughout history have been
angry at epicurian people why do non
epicurian get so angry at epicurian do
you imply that non- epicurian are
seeking some kind of Vengeance against
epicurian because epicurian are living a
happier life so that's wrong wrong
opinion right there we don't know unless
somebody actually shows themselves or
says that they're angry at at epicurian
whether they are saying that people
criticize doesn't mean that they're
angry you can criticize because you
think somebody's got something wrong and
you can criticize in a calm way Cicero
and Plutarch aren't angry at the
epicurian neither is lonus and so to
assume that and project that on them you
got to ask yourself where's that coming
from right so whenever you've got a a
kod doia yeah kod doia um you want to
back up and say how where did I get this
idea from and is it really in accordance
with the facts
um all right so
let's jump to just a few things then
I'll I'll take on these other questions
so anger is very common right it it it
can be part of our temperament it's
often provoked by our environmental
relationships but the epicurian is not
going to like cultivate anger it's not
going to be something that they think is
automatically a good thing they're going
to be suspicious that you know when they
get angry one of the things you could do
is say am I getting angry because I'm
really being harmed here and I do need
to like establish a boundary or set
things right or do I have some wrong
opinions about stuff going on and if we
think about the epican garden right we
do want to um think about how people can
be friendly with each other how how can
households or families um the oos in in
ancient Greek how can that be um
minimizing the amount of of wrongheaded
anger or communities larger communities
that you might participate in your
workplace uh your political Community
all of those are places where probably
other people are going to get ticked off
because they're not you know
philosophically inclined you don't have
to get sucked into that and as we said
cosign their sort of nonsense
right um alligator says I wonder what an
epicurian might say to those instances
when somebody is angry for some reason
when they grieve um okay so I I don't
think you need to be an epicurian to
note that there's a lot of people in our
society and and other societies who are
not great at handling and living with
negative emotions like grief which is a
kind of pain right and they're
more comfortable with feeling anger
instead and this goes for not just grief
but fear or anxiety or shame or guilt
all of these negative emotions can
easily be translated into anger
especially for men um the more Macho
they are the more insecure they are
about their own
masculinity um anger is sometimes the
only permissible you know socially
permissible um emotion to to feel and to
show to other people but you know again
you'd want to ask yourself where did I
get that idea from is that an a true
idea you know let's measure this against
things and
you know I I always so I've mentioned
this before uh how liberating for me as
a um not young man but an adolescent who
had lost his father uh when my dad was
only 36 and I was 11 reading the Odyssey
in middle school and I hadn't cried at
my dad's funeral because I was told
you're the man of the house now you got
to be tough and all that sort of stuff
and reading the Odyssey and realizing
that one of my my great her es this
super super tough guy adicus could be
weeping openly with all of his crew
mates about their lost crew mates that
being a tough guy doesn't mean you can't
cry um how how you know that you don't
have to like go on a rage and and try to
kill people you can actually Express
that emotion um now going back to the
grief thing one of the things sometimes
you see people saying how could you
leave me and they're angry at the Dead
I
mean so I I won't say you should just
simply repress that emotion or ignore it
or something like that but again does it
make sense to actually be angry with the
dead for leaving you I mean if you've
got unfinished business maybe you're
ticked off at them about that because
they did you wrong but that's a whole
other ball game that's being angry with
them because you couldn't like vent your
anger on them uh um so yeah um virtual
nura says can anger be a positive and
worthwhile emotion anger against a
genuine Injustice can be expressed in a
calm and considered manner yeah I mean
the epicurian don't think that anger is
always a bad thing it depends on how
it's you know what it's based on whether
it's based on there's an actual
injury um that you need to like fix or
or address or whether it's based in
empty vain opinions that you have um so
yeah just like the aristotelians just
like the platonists um anger can
sometimes be what is called for the
problem is is that most people wind up
being wrong when they decide that their
anger is actually called for and and you
don't necessarily have to express it in
a calm and considered manner there could
be cases where you're actually being you
know and people you care about is being
attacked and you get angry and you you
retaliate but you don't like Go and Kill
Everybody after that or you know try to
torture people or things like that so
yeah the epicureans think that anger can
sometimes be the right thing um I do
want to point out in Cicero on the
ends um when torquatus is presenting the
virtues as being a central part of
epican um thought which is Echoes the
thought of epicurus as we find it in
diogenes
lieres talks about wisdom or prudence
and Temperance and that these um help us
distinguish and restrain unnecessary and
unnatural desires so they would have
some role in dealing with anger if you
want to from a classical epicurian
perspective if you want to be able to to
manage your anger you need to cultivate
wisdom and you need to cultivate
Temperance so he says um this is
torquatus one who is perpetually swayed
by conflicting and incompatible counsels
and desires can know no peace or calm
and then they talk about mental diseases
um because they they view these
emotional disorders as being a sort of
sickness and so they talk about
extravagant and imaginary desires and
among the examples that torquatus
discuss are the
ill-tempered the defiles and this goes
back to like an you know
um sort of common way of talking about
anger Aristotle had talked about the
kapoy which is you
know it's like a cognant with with
defiles in Latin as people who get angry
easily about trivial stuff and they're
just kind of a pain in the ass you know
so you know what would be the remedy for
that developing the virtues of prudence
and Temperance the last thing I'll say
about epicur then maybe we'll do some
more Q&A and then jump into
lucrecias epicurus talks about our
capacity for memory and the epicurian
developed practices uh involving this so
you know if we were practicing an
epicurian life um we could then remember
how we handled situations and we could
like you know go back over them not in
order to make ourselves feel crappy
about it because that's kind of
pointless from an epican point of view
but in order to develop more Prudence to
make ourselves less prone to anger and
we can focus on remembering past
Pleasures or we can focus on past pains
so holding grudges for example not a
smart thing to do from an Epicurean
perspective because what are you doing
if you hold a grudge you're continually
remembering this thing that this person
did or said or failed to do or say
and you're getting yourself angry about
it again in the present that's almost
the opposite of what you would want to
do but we see lots and lots of people in
the present doing that here we go uh uh
herum says filus says that once the
initial pay of indignation is endorsed
as rational and natural anger it can be
productive if channeled into a course of
action so we can live correctly and
pleasantly so there there it is we're
going to talk about philodemus in the uh
follow-up session that we'll have a
couple months from now about epicurian
because he's he's got so much stuff to
say that I wanted to put him off to the
side but it's good to bring him in and
you know he does have this idea of um
natural versus unnatural anger which he
tells us epicurus himself had virtual
Natura where does the rule of law fit
into the appropriate expression of anger
doesn't really I mean rule of law is a
concept of we all are under the law law
and we all have to follow it and that's
sort of just a general legal principle
if you're saying what do the laws
themselves have to say about anger
remember that for
epicurus there is no absolute you know
um catalone Justice it's always within
particular communities but you can say
that you know we restrict certain things
we we say uh you can't you know if you
are really angry at somebody that
doesn't excuse you going up and punching
the crap out of them right um so you
know what what is that like in different
societies that changes over time um we
live in a time where I'd say there's
less tolerance for expressions of anger
than there used to be a hundred years
ago at least for certain persons but
it's also very power-based right and we
could say not just law but we could talk
about Norms in society are women allowed
to express anger as easily as men are in
many of our societies still not the
case um Braden Kim why do epicurian
desire to spread their philosophy and
Views to other people since they created
these ideas I would assume it comes from
some desire to share it but where does
that desire come from I mean this is a
very simple answer that doesn't just
have to do with
epicurian if you think that you've got
things right and you think that
understanding the world rightly will
make people feel less crappy in their
lives and make you know less poor
decisions why the hell wouldn't you
share it you'd be kind of a jerk to hide
you know your proverbial candle under a
bushel uh it doesn't mean that you have
to like go out and tell everybody oh you
must convert become an epicurian or we
will put you to the sword epicurian
aren't into that sort of thing right um
but whether you're a stoic and epicurian
Aristotelian pick whatever you want if
you think you actually have things
correct why the hell wouldn't you want
the good for other people you know I
mean it's kind of painful to watch
people messing up their lives isn't it
so yeah there we go here him says uh
epicurus closes his letter to mosus
saying practice by yourself and with
others of of like mind very very
important point there epicyon seek to
make other epicurian friends and here
I'm if you want to put something in
theat at like a link to some of the
places that that people can go out there
because there is a an epicurian
Community um I think that would be
really awesome uh alligator if emotions
help in moral
development with aiming to minimize
disturbance overlook this potential for
moral growth sorry if this is way off um
so disturbance you know would be uh I
think what you're thing is trouble uh
you know aaria trying not to be um
bothered by things I mean the sage gets
angry in epicureanism but the sage
doesn't get angry over trivial crap
right the sage gets angry when in the
course of this imperfect life that we
live people are injuring him or her or
people that they care about or their
Community or something like that and
then they you know they do action that
is stemming from that but they don't
like go overboard with
Revenge um and you know even the stoics
think that emotions do help in moral
development there's the upath right the
ones that you ought to be cultivating so
neither the stoics nor the epicureans
are saying don't ever feel emotions but
you do want to you do want to understand
why you're feeling what you're feeling
and actually I want to go to something
else that that herum brought up and
we've talked about a little bit um and
i' I've said this in in a number of
other places about other
matters um very often in ancient
philosophy things are presented to us as
if we're supposed to be we're g you know
we're going to figure all this stuff out
change our characters you know uh
develop good practical
reasoning like on our own and and there
is a good point to that right what if
we're thrown into a situation where we
we can't rely r on anybody else right we
don't know anybody else but I think if
you've got good friendships built up
with people who can call you on your BS
when you're engaging in it you know
whether it's big stuff or little stuff
they can say oh man you're screwing up
you you need to look at things this way
I think that can be really really
helpful and I think you know a lot of
times we want to be able to go to people
and say am I on the right track here or
am I totally off base and I think this
is really important with with anger but
also with other negative emotions you
know there are some things we should
worry about it's a pretty small amount
and then there's other things that we
shouldn't and asking somebody else who's
maybe a little bit further along or just
another pair of eyes am I on the right
track that's something that I think
communities of practice can provide us
with
so all right um Braden says logically I
would think sharing philosophies has
some consequences good and bad going
back to the ideas of natural and
necessary since you can experience pain
and anger when sharing your views um
would epicurian think it's not necessary
or natural I'm not sure what you what
the it um sharing your views I mean not
all not all of our desires so the
natural necessary Matrix is about our
desires and Pleasures um you can share
your views without it necessarily being
Pleasant or painful I mean the epicurian
do share their views right they teach
people in their their Garden epicurus
writes the most out of any author in
Antiquity so presumably it's it's an
enjoyable and worthwhile task for him um
but it you know the the is it based
here's the question you want to ask
yourself with that is it based on empty
opinion or not um now Francis right I
don't know about Francis right so that's
not that's not something that I'm gonna
comment on here and I think that's
probably a bit of a um what do you call
it um going going into the Weeds about
this so I don't know Francis right was a
good epicurian or not um heram maybe
knows but but I don't let's talk about
lucretius so what is lucretius bringing
to the table in on the nature of the
universe so a couple things um you know
as uh somebody who who really pointed
this out well is Albert kamu and um The
Rebel he talks about lucrecias and
epicurus and he says you know lucretius
and I think he's right about this casts
epicurus as a kind of Savior figure a
soor in in uh uh there's actually like
depictions of epicurus as as a savior
figure not just as a founder of a
philosophy but as you know somebody
who's imparting uh wisdom to help us not
be screwed up right to to release human
beings from having to live in fear
irrational fears about all sorts of
stuff um God's anger natural phenomena
he thinks that this is a really
important thing and so um you know
there's some interesting discussions
there one example um lucrecias thinks
that these natural elements like fire
and water and strife with each other and
every once in a while they overcome the
world and then he talks about this
classical myth of faton losing control
of the Chariot of the sun here's where
the anger comes in struck down by Zeus
in his anger and lacrecia says this is
this is a story that we should reject he
says poor Humanity to saddle the Gods
with such responsibilities and to throw
in a vindictive
temper and Lous like epicurus thinks
that you know if you want to have any
sort of connection with the gods other
than just contemplating them you can
picture The Quiet Ones in their
untroubled peace um you know if you if
you do this but you also think about
them as tossed on turbulent waves of
anger you won't go to the temple with a
quiet or tranquil heart so you know the
idea is get rid of these these crazy
ideas about the gods getting angry it's
not going to help you it's not factual
um it just makes you upset and maybe
sets a bad example or makes you worried
that they're gonna Smite you so how does
lucretius um look at anger this happens
a little bit
later in book three where he's setting
out a physical Theory and this is
probably again again coming from
epicurus's on nature so he talks about
these uh Elements which you know makes
sense a lot of the ancient Greeks
thought of things in terms of elements
and in this case it's not you know earth
air fire water it's actually fire or
heat okay so that's similar air a wind
which is cold and then an unnamed
element that is responsible for mind or
Consciousness and all of these come
together
and bodily things are made of these
configurations so when we get angry
there is a predominance of this heat
element in what's going on and it
affects our minds and our bodies and he
he says that some creatures have an
excess of this heat or fire element in
their composition and so this causes
them to have passionate hearts and angry
dispositions the Paradigm case for this
that he uses lions now he says something
that's not factually correct that they
are so angry that they Roar and burst
their breasts as a result but you know
you ever seen a big cat angry it's
pretty damn scary right and there by the
way there were still lions in Europe at
that time they're slowly being you know
extinguished from the the Middle East
and the Mediterranean area so that you'd
only find them uh generally further
south um in in other parts of the world
um so lions are kind of a good example
you know in classical Antiquity we see
others like you know Bears uh wild bores
things things along those lines
right people can be like that too now
whereas animals tend to have this is a
common idea in ancient times animals
tend to have kind of a fixed disposition
so lions are Angry Creatures deer are
fearful creatures because they have too
much of the wind in them um cattle are
kind of flagma because they've got the
air element
predominating we human beings are much
more varied so some people are more like
lions some people are more like cattle
some people are more like um deer
depending on what sort of composition
you have of this stuff in your body just
like when we talked about with Plato
right some people are more
thotics anger and the the things that
are connected with it we human beings
though we can change it now you can't
completely get rid of all if you're an
angry irascible person you can't get rid
of it altoe but you can reduce it as he
says to very small lingering traces
vestigia little Shadows that are left
and how do you do this through education
through training through culture and
most important importantly through
philosophy and so you know studying
epican philosophy according to lucretius
would be a way to do this now you know
maybe we've lost some of those resources
it would be really nice to have EP
epicurus's book on the passions as a
guide book maybe we'll find it at
herculanum you know there's there's a
possibility of that so what is this mean
we have the possibility to change our
nature to some degree he also talks
about Social Development and he talks
about you know human beings forming
societies and then eventually they're
worn out by this constant violence
within societies and he talks about this
distaste for a life of violence came
naturally to a society where every
individual was ready to gratify his
anger by a harsher Vengeance than is now
tolerated by Equitable laws so having
laws in place that say if somebody
crosses you you can't do anything you
like to them you know you can't have
blood feuds going on for Generation
after generation we have to work these
these sorts of things out that's a sign
of human progress according to lucretius
and lucrecias has like you know a whole
account of this and this is in uh book
five of the the uh on the nature of
things so we see that both in a societal
way and for in individuals or small
groups anger is something that has a
natural basis it's got a function but it
can be made worse or better through what
we do with ourselves through culture you
know if we're getting wrong messages
from the culture like hey man if
somebody crosses you you better take
revenge on them you if we're watching
like action films all the time probably
not a good influence right um if we're
if we're also telling people oh you
should never ever ever get angry that's
a bad thing that's probably not a good
idea either right so our culture our
education our habituation what we choose
to do with our s the relationships that
we're in all of those can help to make
us less angry people and steer us
towards having just rational natural
anger that's rooted in in you know a
real reflection of how things are so the
epican will get angry until we live in
some sort of Utopia right um but they're
probably not going to get angry very
much and they're not going to want to
seek out occasions to get angry so they
wouldn't be like rage posting right
they're not going to be participating in
online pylons on people or anything like
that um and you know maybe they would
help to correct each other as well so
all right uh virtual nura could we
change human nature to reduce anger by
eliminating the male gender I mean no
because I mean it's it's ridiculous to
think that uh men and women don't get
equally angry um all you got to do is
spent much time with them and by the way
Plato noted that way back in the
Republic right uh men and women can
equally have thumos um what makes people
think that they don't wrongheaded ideas
again kod doia um so no that that
wouldn't help anything there are so many
different ways in which anger can be
displayed as a matter of fact some
ancient thinkers actually attributed
anger more to women than to men believe
it or not so that's a non-starter right
there even if it were physically
possible any other questions
clarifications
comments um will wrap up fairly soon
because I got to do some other things
but a lot of useful questions at this
point while people are writing them I'll
mention that next month we're going to
look at Cicero and his references and
discussions of anger so we're talking
about primarily tusculan disputations
but
also uh on duties book one and a few
other texts as well and then we're going
to Veer off for a little while into
stoics we're going to look at senica's
whole book on anger and then uh the
month after that so um March there'll be
May we'll be looking at epicus and
Marcus aelius and their remarks about
anger and I haven't decided what we're
going to do after that we might come
back to some more literary stuff or even
look at some medical authors or come
back to Philo damus I'm holding out out
probably
ridiculously hope that we might get some
some new philus stuff at least you know
tantalizing hints of it coming out um
from the herculin am Scrolls since they
are making progress on that um that
would be very cool if that happens but
you know how much hope should we place
in that maybe not not so much uh but
that's what we have coming up Amy says
this has been so interesting uh thank
you you're very welcome yeah we do this
every month um usually we do this later
in the month but I had to move some
other events around my world's of
speculative fiction is usually on this
second Saturday of the month but since I
have a special thing happening the
author of the The Two works and this is
a totally different series of uh Bride
of the tornado and dare to know James
Kennedy from Chicago will be joining us
for the session and he couldn't do it
this weekend because he's got a special
book release thing happening but um for
bride of the tornado but we'll be doing
um we'll be doing that later this month
Mark says if our friend is insulted and
we feel that they should be justifiably
angry and stand up for themselves but
they choose not to should we be led by
our anger on their behalf to stand up
for them or should we respect their
choice and back down too that's a good
one um that's one of those things where
there isn't like a single hard and fast
rule I think right
um I I suppose it would depend on first
of all whether we think we can actually
do something about it so feasibility you
could say and is our friend going to be
pushed away by us acting on their behalf
or are they is there an expectation that
we're going to act on their beh half
those are some things that we would want
to take into consideration but I don't
think that there's a single answer to
that um Andy
says if I remember correctly lucretius
placed value on friendship and Community
is key components of a happy life
wouldn't he say that anger undermines
social harmony and the bonds between
individuals suggesting an overcoming
anger is not only beneficial for
personal Tranquility well I mean if you
want to know what He suggests read the
book
that's that's the the the simplest thing
uh he doesn't say that we must overcome
anger in order to have social
Tranquility nor nor would he I mean
epicurus didn't say that and epicurus
seemed to think that there's some cases
where we we should get angry so why
would lucretius say that and if you
think about it people oftentimes need to
have other people get angry with them
and say man you're acting like an a-hole
knock it off right in order to have that
social harmony it's a false Harmony to
never get angry at anybody right even
the stoics who think that the emotion of
anger isn't good will say sometimes you
need to appear to be angry so that
people who are doing the wrong thing can
get the message that they better knock
it off so you know um in in a great
relationship you probably don't need to
get angry with each other but you
probably also need to get angry along
the way with people I mean one of the
best life lessons that I had as an Angry
Young Man was having somebody uh who was
angry with me and who was not willing to
like talk with me as a result say act
like an [__] get treated like an
assle I needed to hear that at that time
and that helped me straighten out you
know so heram is right there's little
possibility of moral development for
ourselves and our friends if we banish
natural anger yeah I mean from the Epic
Ian point of view and the Aristotelian
and the platonic the stoics would be the
outliers in this respect we need rightly
directed anger in order to have good
relations there's you know you're not
happy at the time that you're angry and
it seems like things are disrupted but
what's the result you know um think
about how cats play with each other
right um and cats by the way somebody
says my cat never gets angry well you
got a weird cat then cuz most cats do
get angry and I just experienced it last
weekend when I had to take uh one of the
cats and put him into a room that he
didn't want to be in and he escaped
twice and by the second the the second
time I was bringing him in there he was
pretty pissed off at me how do cats
actually learn what's okay what's not
okay they learn it as kittens by being
aggressive with each other and then
getting smacked down by the other cats
you know the other cats hiss at them the
other cats you know knock them around
and then after a while they're like oh I
better not act like a like a jerk
anymore I better not indulge my my
desires in the way that I I want to we
human beings are a lot more like that
we're a predator creature you know
naturally we're not a herd prey creature
like horses or cows or I mean goats are
kind of like a little bit more like us
um some human beings are much more
Placid that's nice but a lot of us need
to learn these lessons along the way so
so this notion of natural anger quite
important uh in this and uh there's a
productive role for for anger the thing
we have to watch is
mistaking any feeling that we have where
we think we're Justified for actually
being justified thinking that we're
actually injured when we're not injured
and stuff like that
Elijah says what resources may help
anger over an unjustifiable
history Plato thinks anger would result
from lack of virtue that's false but
virtue cannot provide the desired
justification increasing anger Plato
thinks that you need to be angry at
times um and so do the platonist thumos
is an integral part of Justice itself
right so um Plato doesn't doesn't think
that anger results automatically from
lack of virtue and I I don't know what
an unjustifiable history like you mean
like where there's bad blood between
people um I mean what resources the same
resources as we find in everything else
um sort of looking at philosophical
practices and you know trying to get
your mind right about these sorts of
things and you know the epicurian just
like stoics just like the platonists
just like you know a lot of others uh
they had a philosophy as a way of life
where you you engage in whether you want
to call them spiritual exercises like P
Ado calls it or Technologies of the self
like Fuko calls it or just you know
philosophical exercises or a skasis
that's that's what you're doing and it's
an ongoing process some of that I guess
would be cognitive you know figuring out
is this history that we have really
unjustifiable or if it is do I have to
get pissed off about it you know that
that could be part of it is it
productive response to be angry at
things that happened in the past that I
can't change now that might be a way to
to look at it
so all right any other questions
comments um clarifications
issues not seeing any at the time um
hear a lot of noise coming from next
door it sounds like they're having a
little party uh probably doing a little
day drinking as well oh Mark says who's
next on the menu so Cicero um we're
going to be looking at um tusculan
disputations three and
four
um I mentioned uh on the on the ends
we'll probably look at uh um some of the
stuff in there but mostly on D's book
one and then I also want to attend to
some of the rhetorical Dimensions so
he's he's got some rhetorical works like
on the oror that would be
relevant uh alligators are an
overreliance on rational thought I think
humans are more irrational I don't have
no idea what you're asking there is
there an overreliance on rational
thought where among epic
carians um no no more than there is with
any philosophy if it's an actual
successful philosophy and the fact I
mean you think that humans are more
irrational I guess you should ask
yourself where you're getting that you
know idea from That's So sweeping and
why would why would that imply that we
shouldn't be more rational you know
there's a lot of assumptions I think
rolled into there um but I you know it's
hard to answer these very elliptical
questions because they're a little bit
too General ah here we go like my own
anger is often impulsive so it's not
human beings as such that you're worried
about it's you that's a whole different
question um well you can look at your
anger and there's all sorts of ways of
doing this modern psychology has
approaches ancient philosophy has
approaches which are often copied from
you know the the modern psychologist
when they're successful often copied
ancient
philosophy um there's all sorts of ways
of of looking at that and uh you can
figure out whether your own anger is too
irrational and impulsive um but but
thinking that humans per se are too
irrational or that you shouldn't become
more rational that that's not going to
be helpful for you I think you want to
focus in on on what where your own anger
is coming from and whether you can fix
it or not right all right well we're
getting close to the end of the time
I've got a lotted any other last
questions
comments
issues
matters um
by the way if you're interested in the
previous um nine sessions there's a
playlist that uh you can easily just
Google uh understanding anger 2.0 and
you should be able to find it um and uh
I'm going to be creating uh some some
places where people can find the
resources but I've got a lot of things
on the plate right now so um oh heam
thanks very nice to get that feedback
from you uh because we you know got a
genuine long
practicing uh uh epicyon in the room
group leader uh author so that's that's
very nice Mark says what would be your
epicurian take on the intersection
between pleasure and anger and heavy
metal just passing thoughts I mean you
know it's interesting so I'll go out on
this
one there's there's a a perception
and I think it's a similar perception
with um with rap as well oh heavy metal
so angry so aggressive it's bad for
these people you know it like my mom
used oh such angry music I don't know
how you can listen to that you know and
they've done studies social scientific
studies and they' found that um people
who are heavy metal fans are very often
not provoked to anger and AGG ivity by
listening to heavy metal it often has a
calming effect on them not on everybody
else so this is where we got to like be
you know kind of like uh prudent and
qualify stuff um you know people take
solace in in music people uh use it to
pump themselves up at the gym people do
all sorts of things with music and it is
Pleasant to listen to music right the
kind of music that you like there's
other kinds of music that you don't like
and you're like I don't want to hear
this crap you know and that varies
significantly from people to to people
so all right virtual Nur I'm trying to
learn about the Life of Francis right I
would appreciate any of your thoughts if
you have an opportunity to do research
about her that is not on my radar at all
I I have so many different projects
going on the only way that I ever like
Veer from my already established plans
is when somebody hires me to tutor them
or produce videos about somebody else
because I you know my reading list is
very very packed I have book reviews I
teach
classes um I I you know it the the
people that I'd really like to get to
you know uh Mary W stonecraft I've been
meaning to write stuff on her for a very
long time so I'm afraid that Francis
Wright uh is probably not g to be
somebody who I do work work on unless I
wind up being commissioned about it and
then I put my other stuff on on hold for
the time being all right so I'm going to
wrap up here it's 1:30 in Milwaukee
whatever it happens to be I know Mark is
over in South Africa here him's on the
same time is me whatever it is where you
are I hope you have a good rest of the
day or night or morning or whatever it's
going to be and uh I will see you next
time